[Music]
the biden administration's plan to buy
500 million covid vaccine doses and
donate them to the lowest income nations
in the world
is part of a global push to give
everybody equal access to this vaccine
so take a look at this map the darkest
shades of red like the us
canada and china and parts of europe are
dominating in the race to vaccinate
their citizens
these wealthy nations are doing far
better than the countries that you see
here in the yellow
in africa look at this less than one
percent of the population is fully
vaccinated less than one percent several
countries on that continent
shown here in white have not given any
doses at all
deborah patter reports from south africa
deborah good morning to you
good morning here at this vaccine
station in sweter the elderly are
finally being immunized
it's a far cry from the u.s which is
already vaccinating children
while across the border from south
africa there are health workers
who have not received a single jab
nurse menzien cormor is up with the
rooster's crow
he's trying to stay strong after
fighting the pandemic for over a year
with nothing more than a mask
but with no vaccines available in the
tiny kingdom of eswatini
he's not ready for the third wave our
country
does not afford even the simple symbol
treatment
for the covet patients worried about
infecting his family
he lives at the encuena clinic it's the
first line of defense against the virus
for the local community
the fact that the us is already
vaccinating children
is cause for hope he says it's just that
that hope is not for him you know that
there is
something that can assist you that can
save
more lives but you can't access it it's
so painful
because it's like we live in another
world
the country has already exhausted its
meager supply of vaccines
just over 30 000 health workers have
received their first shot
and cormor was not one of them if
wealthy nations are able to vaccinate
children
they should be sharing excess doses
believe south africa's pandemic advisor
dr
salim abdul karim to me it's
unconscionable
that a country vaccinates lotus people
when
a whole lot of other countries
especially in africa
haven't even vaccinated their health
care workers that's an unacceptable and
ethically and
immorally unacceptable situation
africa has only received under 50
million doses
compared to the over 2 billion
administered worldwide
and there are enough vaccines to tackle
the global shortage
right now says the head of africa's cdc
john
song so we are not actually begging for
vaccines we are just saying let's have
an arrangement
where you can delay your vaccines a
little bit there's absolutely no reason
why
in some countries you have four or five
times more vaccines sitting
in deep freezers the enemy he reminds us
is the virus menzian cormor knows
exactly who that enemy is
and that lifting weights won't keep
covert at bay
his only real weapon is a vaccine
africa was relying on india for vaccines
but that supply has been halted
due to their own covert crisis so
donations of american vaccines will be
most welcome
deborah patter there reporting for us
from south africa deborah
thank you very much